[Music]
well the migrant caravan from Honduras
was headed for this country but was
stopped short in Mexico and is now
occupying the border city of Tijuana
local residents in Tijuana are getting
increasingly fed up about its presence
anar Lopez is a municipal delegate for
downtown Tijuana he recently said that
the caravan leaders tricked people into
traveling north was fault with false
promises yes is that Caravan members
would be better off returning to their
home countries Delia Lopez joins us
tonight Mr Lopez thank you very much for
coming on hi good evening from Tijuana
thanks thank you I'm looking at a
picture of you with some kind of
encampment behind you will you tell our
viewers what we're looking at yes we're
outside of sports facility we called una
dad benito juarez and this was like an
emergency shelter for them when they
first got here that were like 360
migrants come in here and they walk all
the way to the border where the border
mids are surf because they were going to
try and cross through the see through
the beach or jump the fence and when we
stopped them there we had to bring them
over here because the neighbors from
from that from that part of town
it's called playa de Tijuana is like
Tijuana by the sea they were getting mad
and they if they even started throwing
stones at each other so we have more
here like 360 but things got out of hand
because we kept growing and growing this
is a federal issue that is not a
municipal issue but we were carrying the
load the financial load of of keeping
these people with medicine food shelter
blankets and whatever and Wisconsin is
taking help from the I'm sorry to
interrupt but behind you it seems that
somebody is cleaning up garbage is there
a lot of trash there there's a lot of
trash because what I was trying to tell
you the 360 grew to 6200 and that's what
is what got our hand so we got another
facility it's a big concert hall where
you can have like 10,000 people on there
a roof we send them over here but it has
to be voluntary because the people from
human rights they have their delegates
here too and they want to treat have
wanted to treat them to kindly so the
ones who didn't want to go are staying
here so there was like 1500 people here
there's 2200 people there and there's
like 2,000 people that we aren't
accounted for unaccounted for what do
you think so those basically you have
illegal aliens from Honduras in Tijuana
how do you feel that yeah
well I've heard that like Border Patrol
has been going up into tensions like 100
150 what the tensions are they that
they're used to there was an accident in
freeway 8 that connects San Diego to
Calexico I think there were three on
Durin's there on that accident there
were like eight people in a pickup truck
bed and so some of them have made it
across not a lot but some of them but
most of them some are staying here
they're the ones that are outside here
on the street they said because they
already started their their paperwork
for getting work permits here in Mexico
they want to stay in Mexico they know
that they somebody popped the bubble of
their American Dream and they're staying
here like 200 have been repatriated home
voluntarily and we have deported more
than 200 there's been like 236 detained
by police and we send those to the
immigration system so you you're dealing
with several thousand unwanted
immigrants in Tijuana the United States
right now has about 22 million illegal
aliens living within our borders
can you understand now that you're
you're seeing this firsthand the
frustration of some Americans about that
yeah yeah people here that the people
from Tijuana are frustrated if these
people came here legally if they went to
our border and they started you know
work visa student visa truce visa there
would be no problem Allah Allah
do that and they try to work up to to
the border and they try to do their
their paperwork also in with C VPN and
your authorities to go legally into the
United States a lot of them have
families there a lot of them have
families in Canada I've talked with
people from the Canadian embassy they
have program that unites family Mexicans
who are or Hondurans who are working
there and and they have visas for that
but these guys didn't cross illegally
into Mexico they tore down our beginning
and jump then they started this Caravan
and right down the state that I was like
8200 it's not a big no-no Robert
effective what happens in the United
States but it there well it's not but
I'm sympathetic so so finally how are
you gonna respond when this happens
again because this will not likely be
the last Caravan that comes through
Tijuana yes we have a change of
president this president has a very
different mindset from the last person
this president says welcome we're going
to give you jobs we're going to great
create opportunities for you and things
like that and we're worried in definer
we're worried because they're saying
that but they're not helping us we don't
we aren't we aren't getting any federal
help right now and we're waiting for
that to happen and in the next days the
other shelter this was in charge of the
town of Tijuana the other shelter we're
gonna turn over to the federal
authorities and they have to take care
of it well we feel for you Mr Lopez and
I hope you'll come back on and tell them
tell us how it's going
thank you very much we hope we get
better before it gets worse